"Pongo VS Missles", huh?
DODGE 'EM UP!
You think I'm afraid
of your furrrkin missles
BRUH!!!
Oh-hoh-hoh-hoh.
Oh-hoh-hoh-hoh!
AAAAARAGHARRHAAAAAHHH!!!
The dildo was too big!
You ain't gonna get past my defence!
I've improved the strength of my butt-cheeks
and you ain't
NEEEVER
gonna---
OOHOHOHOH MY GOD!
What--- OH GOD!
Alright, this time
is going to be the winner
because i'm just going to lie flat.
Present my buttocks...
to the OOAAARGH!!!
Hohoh, hohoh,
HWAHOH!
HWAHOHOH!
Eehh
Eehhha hahOh...
Hohohohohoho
WhoahohoHOHO!
HohowhaHAha!
You're all a bunch o' liars!
OH GOD, DON'T KILL ME!!!
AHHAHA Don't do it!
I don't want to die!
AAAAAARGH!!!
AAAAAAARGH!!!!
Lilil!
LILILILILOO!
AAAAARGH!!!
Oh, f***!
Did I win?
YES!
Okay!
Whoa! You troll!
I saw that last one...
Hi buddy!
How are you doin'?
O MAI GAWRSH!
I have to hop over you.
Well how-dee-do!
I know it's not exactly a "western thing"
to be in a desert
and talk all southern to a camel.
But, oh boy!
You have the lifeless, soulless eyes of a demon.
Excuse me, while I just pump on your rumpy hump.
BOINK!
Free throw! Bpla Bplonis, if I can AAAAARRGH!1!
GOD!!!
No-ho-ho!
Ahh, I'm still alive-
Ahh, God Dammit!
I wasn't ready for that!
Am I alive?
No, those were just the spasms of the baby stabbing me.
Hello!
Ok...
Alright, lets try this one more time
with less stupid.
And what is with my legs?
Alright that'll...
that'll stop 'em!
Yep!
That'll all..
Oh..
Hey, let me just hold ya...
I'll take this from ya!
Ahhh! God dammit, mah face!
Wait, you demon children,
aren't gonna get the best of me!
I know how to defeat you!
Apparently I don't- holy shit.
I'll just... oh my god!
I didn't mean it!
AAAUGH!
Oh nooooo!
Noooooo!
I had that!
You think you can beat me? Ohh jeez...
You can probably beat me through that...
Uh, that ain't good.
THAT AIN'T GOOD!
GIVE GIVE GIVE GIVE AAH GIVE GIVE GIVE GIVE
AAAAUUUHHH!
GOT IT!
Oooh I got him!
(Mark's evil laugh)
YYYYEAH!
Oh.
OH!
Oh hello!
Why am I grabbing the death ball???
Ooh, this probably isn't good.
IIIIII'M SORRRRYY!
OH JEEZ I'M SORRY! OH GOD!
Oh these people are just having a nice picnic
out by the car park!
Aaauuuhhh god
AAHH HE'S TAKING A SHIT!
Rope soccer 3.0-
WAUGH!
YEAAAAH!
I've never played a game of soccer
in my life!
Can you tell?!?
Hnnnnnnnn...
The impossible.
I WILL SEE ABOUT THAT!
HUAAAAH PLEH!
AAUUHHHAHAHA!
I've been flombe'd.
Alright,
Don't-AAAHH!
OH HOHOHOHOHOHOHOHOHOHOHO
OKAY.
IS IT OVER?
HAAH!
Oh shit... that ain't gonna do it.
WOAH!
OH GOD MY-
WWOOOAHH!
Hohohoho
HANG MAN GAMEZ!
TYPE THE BOX.
Ooh really?
UH, IS THERE AN S ?
Damn it!
R?
SSSHHIIIIT!
T?
Or a F?
U?
O?
I?
WHAAT?!?
A!
Alright, P!
L!
E!
YYYYYEEEAAHHH!
Okay.
3D Challenge!
The fastest wins a shoutout in my next level!
Well, i'm already not fastest because I-
WOOOOOAAWOOAWOAHWOAH
WOOOOAW OKAY!
(pretending to die)
ROPE SWING 12 DESERT!
EEUHH!
AAAAAHHHHH GOD WHY-
MY HEAD IS IN MY ANOOS!
MY HEAD IS IN MY ANOOOOOOHOOHOOS!!!!
Slide right through!
Ooohoohoojeez! Not like that!
SLOJIT!
OOOOOOH!
WITH BARELY MINIMAL DAMAGE! I'm da best!
LLOOOOOooong spike fall!
OK.
Alright!
Ok!
Heheheaurhuhuhuhushet-
UUUARGH!
MUH BUUTT!
LLOOOOOooong spike fall!
Lil' bit farther out.
Do I need to pull back? forward?
Am I on the money?
Am I-- OOOOOH YES!
STILL DEAD!
STILL DEATH!
(santaplier voice) KIDDIES!
OH I think we're on the wrong level!
*Unintelligible*
AAAAH I'm not gonna let that stop me!
Thank you, kiddies!
that guy was reeeaaaly annoying!
REAUghuuuuuuugh (death noise)
(regular voice) Lots of stuff!
OOOOOO
KAAY?
AAAAAAGH MY BUTT!
Ok, well that turned out pretty well for me!
I dunno what's gonna happ- oh shit.
EEUAH SHEH
HAH EN EUGH SHYENYE
HAAAAAH YENSLEH
AAAAHH You go by, too!
ok!
And then one more for the rooooad
Nope.
Get away.
Alright, spike fall! I can do this!
Huhehahehuaehuaehuhho!
AHAHO!
WOAHAHO! WOHOHO! WO-
OW.
Mah butt.
Don't move!
Wooeugh god.
I don't know if I should move.
eah!
I MOVED JUST A TINY BIT!
IS THAT GONNA RUIN EVERYTHING?
(weird noise)
SURVIIIVE!
AAAAHH!
I'M JUST AN OLD MAAN!
OOOHOOOHOOOOO!
WUAAAGH!
DON'T KILL ME!
I'M JUST AN OLD MAN!
AH!
OH!
I AM SELF SACRIFICING MAYBE?
YEEEAAAHH
ANOTHER IMPOSSIBLE L- there's a hooole there!
(wheezy laugh)
AAUUU HAHA GOD DAMMIT!
FUCK YOU!
ALRIGHT FINE!
TWO CAN PLAY THAT GAME!
IMMA GO IN DA HOLE!
AAAAUUUGHH IT WENT IN MY HOLE!
SHIT!
Alright, apparently this one's dicking with me!
HAHAHA! OOOOAAAUUUGHHH!
AM I ALIVE?
AAAUUGH GOD NO!
IN THE HOHOHOHOOOOLE!
THIS IS A BIIIIIT-
DYA Fuck you!
HABIFFIGER
aw fuck- EEEEEEUUUUGHHHHH!
UHEUBVU
HWAA!
HOKAY Everything's fine!
HOOOOOOO Golly golly golly golly!
AAAAUGHH!
OOOH FUCK!
Hedebe. Hedeb. OHHHHHOHOHOHO!!!
OOOHHHH GOOHAHAD!!! NOOOO!!
Heh. Wooo weeeeeoooohhh ok.
Everything's fine! HAAH!
[While singing] EVERYTING'S GONNA BE FIIINEE IN MY LIIFFFEEE!!
Ah, ok, everything's still... kinda fine Hope-don't
[Monkey-like sounds of amazement]
YEAHA!! Ok!
Alright!
Oh no.
Oh no, not a torture chamber. Oh no! I don't wanna click!
Why do I gotta click it?
Ok!
Pretty par for the course when it comes to Happy Wheels! Click. Uhg.  Not really torture
more execution chamber. Well this ain't gonna be good
Oh god! Oh, I'm so sorry! Why the boomboxes? Whoa, that's why the boom box!
Oh god, no! Just JUMP, dude! No!
Huh, alrighty then. OH! Pelvic
thrust
OH YEAH! BUT SLAM COMBO!
Holy shit, how are you doing this,
man?! And how do you have such a
strong grundle? Wow.
Welcome to Pogo fight three
YOU READY OLD MAN?! Fu--uhh that was just a warm-up I just want to intimidate farm
COMIN' AT YOU EVENTUALLY!
That's right, that's what I thought. All
right. You ready old lady?
That's right, I called you old! Gonna kill him with your machete and
that was actually a pretty good move.
OHH SHIT, MY TOWER NOW, BITCH!
OHH FUCK YOU! YEAH I BREAK YOUR KNEES! AND YOUR TORSO. Oh no, I've broken
everything of yours
Hello hatchet head! How you doing? Do you like your hat with hedges hatch says...
Hello!... King Towering Hat of Machette! Aww shit.
The Horrors Park. Oh no, it's so spoopy out here
AHH!! OOHHOHOHOHOHEY! What're you doin' overthere?
You think-- whooOOAAHHHooo! Was not a ghosty goo?
Oh god, indeed! YOU AIN'T GONNA GET ME!
You ain't gonna get me. Ain't nobody gonna get me.
Oh, what do I do here? Oh- SHHEEEYET! AHH! Well, took care of her!
Glad that happened! OOWW MY buuUUUTT!!!
Well, I've got this permanent addition to my family.
And I'll never ever get out of here
again. Eh. EH! AHH! Aw f***.
OH IT'S JUST DRIVING IT FURTHER UP MY ANOOOS!
[Outro] This has benn Happy Wheels Highlights! Thanks for watching! If
you want to see more happy wheels right
right now, check the description or click the annotation for the full Happy Wheels
playlist. And if you want to see more
Happy Wheels in the future, please click
the "like button" to let me know. Thanks again everyone, and as always I will see
YOU...
in the next video!
BUH-BYE!!